Only explain to you how you can live an
easy life,
accomplishing goals and be successful
and going out in the world and as tough.
The only way to live an easy life is to
basically give up on all your dreams and
aspirations and just sit around doing
nothing.
Shit.
The diseases is not worth accomplishing.
Therefore a life that is easy.
It's not even worth living.
Nothing in this world is worth having or
doing unless it means effort,
pain,
and difficulty.
Would you listen to me?
You are going to die.
All of you,
you all,
your friends,
your family,
everyone you know,
everyone you care about is going to die
if you love life,
not waste time because time is what life
is made of.
If you respect and appreciate the time
that you've been given while you out
there doing what you want to do,
what you need to be telling yourself is
acceptable to be sitting around
procrastinating and I no longer wants to
be a loser.
I no longer wanted to be offered.
I know what it is that I want and I'm
going to work hard and I'm going to get
it.
When you want to succeed,
as bad as you want to breathe,
then you'll be successful.
Somebody lost sleep more than a lot of
success,
and I'm here to tell you the day if
you're going to be successful,
you've got to be willing to give up
sleep.
You got to be willing to work off for
three hours of sleep,
two hours.
If you really want to be successful,
some days you will have to stay up three
days in a row.
You don't need to
if you don't really want to.
Are you wanting success rather than
actually working towards your dreams?
A lot of you are just thinking about it.
I have high hopes for everybody watching
this.
I want to remember your name.
It is not the things we do in life that
we regret on our deathbed.
It is the things we do not because I
assure you I've done a lot of really
stupid things.
None of them bother me.
All the mistakes and all the dopey
things and all the time I was
embarrassed.
They don't matter.
Find your passion and in my experience,
no matter what you do at work,
what you do in official settings,
that passion will be grounded in people
grounded in the relationships you have
with people and what they think of you.
When your time comes
in,
the teeth stupefying odds,
which is urine by in our ordinariness
that are here.
One thing I do every single day of my
life trying to find somebody else change
their life.
I waited till 39 to get married because
I had to wait that long to find someone.
Her happiness was more important,
and if nothing else,
I hope that all of you can find that
kind of passion and that kind of love in
your life.
Thank you.
We have granted the opportunity to
understand why our eyes open and why
they see what they do in the short time
before they close forever.